doc you better back up we don't have
enough run to get up tables we're going
we don't need if there's anything that
movies had taught us if you have access
to a wormhole a souped up a sports car
or a questionably sanitary hot tub you
can pretty much punch your ticket to
travel through time and space but before
you go jetting off to the future to find
out who wins the World Series for back
in time to invent the Internet or do you
feel someone's mom to ensure a victory
for the machines over the human race
there are some things you need to know
every time travel movies stretches the
genre with different answers to
questions like what is time and how does
time travel work so to make things easy
we've broken time travel into 3d Peters
theory 1 the multiverse timeline time is
made of alternate dimensions and
parallel universes so 2009 Star Trek
movie utilizes this rules
Spock's actions and universe where
Captain Kirk is hunky with smoldering
eyes does not affect universe where
Captain Kirk is well William Shatner
both universes exist equal theory number
two the dynamic timeline time is
flexible and evolving this theory is
also known as the butterfly effects one
small change can impact the president
and the future the rules of this theory
will cause existential contradictions
known as the grandfather paradox where
if a man goes back in time and kills his
grandfather he would cease to exist but
if he were never born
how many have time traveled and then
killed his grandfather in the first
place existential contradictions aside
and Back to the Future Marty McFly
breaks this rule by interfering with his
parents hooking up his existence is
compromised so now if he wants to exist
yes to play wingman for his dad theory
number three the fixed timeline time is
predestined as a time traveler your role
in history was always to go back in time
creating a
in physics this is known as the Novikov
self-consistency principle is there a
grandfather paradox no in this theory
when the grandson goes back in time to
kill his grandfather he will not be able
to do it the gun won't fire where some
other hand of fate will intervene to
prevent the grandson from killing his
grandfather in Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban Harry and Hermione
used the time Turner to go back in time
to get some information their actions do
not cause any new events it's all a
recursive loop as for time itself
experts remain divided some say it's
linearly a VHS tape you may have to
travel back in time to learn about one
of those that plays forward but time
travel involves rewinding the tape and
erasing everything to that most reading
and new is some say time is not winning
that the past present and future exists
all at the same time so taking into
account all these theories
contradictions and paradoxes the best
explanation may be from Jeff Daniels and
looper this is kind of travel crap just
fries your brain like an A which
time-travel theory do you believe what's
your favorite time-travel movies
let us know in the comments below
[Music]